obviously very sad the result we've
achieved and very sad at those
colleagues that lost their seats in the
election and very sad for many people in
this country who will now have a
government that is continuing policies
of austerity and many of the poorest
communities I think suffer very badly
from the economic strategy that I
suspect the Prime Minister will take
forward but also I have pride in our
manifesto that we put forward and all
the policies we put forward which
actually had huge public support on
issues of universal credits the green
Industrial Revolution and investment for
the future but this election was taken
over ultimately by brexit and we as a
party represent people who both voted
remain and leave and my whole strategy
was to reach out beyond the BRICS it
divide to try and bring people together
because ultimately the country has to
come together so what went wrong
well those in leave areas in some
numbers voted for brexit or conservative
candidates which meant that we lost a
number of seats and we didn't make the
gains that I'd hoped we could have done
particularly in the Midlands and
Yorkshire in the north as listening to
some call isn't to are we see this
morning and spring to people who
knocking on door steps and the same from
the shadow health secretary before the
election saying the same thing that
actually you're part of the problem is
this is now time to accept that perhaps
your leadership may have contributed to
this result well I've done everything I
could to lead this party done everything
I could to develop its policies and
since I became leader the membership has
more than doubled and the party has
developed a very serious radical yes but
serious and fully costed manifesto and
I've received more personal abuse than
any other leader has ever received by a
great deal of the media now that happens
all the time I will talk to our national
executive about what we do in the future
I called for last night a period of
collection in the party and obviously
the ruling body of the party our
national executive will decide what
process we follow them for the election
of a successor to me but I quite
prepared and I was elected to do so to
lead the party until that takes place
that some of those voters mentioned
things like sympathizing with the IRA
anti-semitism failing to deal with it
making a party that's to London centric
and ultimately being too left-wing again
do you not accept that those are parts
some of the things that have attached
themselves to you that have made you a
less electable is ending Universal
Credit and paying the waspy women and
having a green Industrial Revolution two
left-wing they are huge issues that face
our country and I think our manifesto
did face up to all of that of the
attacks that have been made on me I have
dealt with the issues that have been
raised I inherited a system that didn't
work in the Labor Party on anti-semitism
I introduced the rule change is
necessary to deal with it and they are
in operation but I think anti-semitism
is an absolute evil curse within our
society and I would always condemn it
and will always do and always well once
again the left if you when Labour's gone
further to the left as it did on to
Michael foot they've lost badly the
Conservatives do you think that korban
ISM is dead it's not it's not Corbin ISM
there is no such thing as Corbin ISM
there is socialism there is social
justice there are radical manifestos all
of which are there but are they also
unelectable no I don't think they are
unelectable at all I think the issue
that dominated this election ultimately
was brexit our policies I've named some
there are many more many others I could
name were actually all of them
individually very popular there was no
and there was no huge debate or
disagreement in the party about any of
the policies in our manifesto the issue
was ultimately the prime minister said
he's going to get breaks it's or - it is
a mirage of nonsense because he knows
perfectly well that he's either got to
get an agreement with the European Union
or he's going to spend seven years
negotiating with the United States and I
am worried about the effect on our
manufacturing industry and our trading
position in that period you don't think
more sent centrist David Miliband kind
of character could have done better
could have beaten Boris Johnson I don't
think the result would have been any
different because we have to make an
appeal to people who vote both voted
both leave and remain and we appeal to
all on a manifesto which would bring
about more social justice in this in
this country and I am proud of the
campaign that we fought the effort that
I put into that campaign and the effort
that hundreds of thousands of people did
who saw in what we were saying
particularly a lot of young people saw
and what was saying some hope for
themselves some future where they
wouldn't go into debt just because they
wanted an education some of your MPs
have have turned on you as well your
candidates you didn't get elected I'll
just quote one prominent Labour Party
figure Allen Johnson who said who summed
up some of the feeling when he said I
want momentum gone he made it made it
sound like it was a kind of parasite
that had sucked the electability out of
the party do you accept that momentum
has been this kind of internal party
within a party how do you feel about
Johnson asking for it well I I don't
agree with Allen Johnson on this and
there are many candidates who are not
necessarily on the left of the party who
were very great for them very happy for
the support that momentum supporters
gave them in the campaign and momentum
is an organization of lots of people's
actually quite a wide range of political
views they see themselves as an activist
base they see themselves as people that
are organizing communities and community
action in our society I think that's
actually a very healthy Democratic
development and it's a different style
of doing politics but I think what we've
shown over the past
for years since I became leader this
growth in membership in this growth of
community activism actually is healthy
for politics and healthy for democracy
and I regret those kind of comments
because I think they're very unfair do
you feel at all guilty that Boris
Johnson has got another five years at
number ten and you feel that it's all
responsible and guilty for that I did
everything I possibly could to win this
election I did everything I possibly
could in order to bridge the divide
between those that voted leave and those
that voted remain because at the end of
the day they're gonna live in a country
where we're going to need that
investment for the future we're gonna
have if this government stays in office
more homelessness more divisions and
more a bigger gap between the richest
and the poorest and so I did everything
I could of course I take responsibility
for putting the manifesto forward but I
have to say the manifesto was
universally supported throughout our
party and throughout our movement so as
I said in my own count result last night
we don't give up on the eternal hopes of
a more decent society and the urgent
demand to make our contribution for a
sustainable world and that's exactly
what our manifesto our Green Industrial
Revolution would have done you talked
about last night period of reflection
before you stand down you wouldn't lead
the party into another general election
when when are you planning on scaling
down well the National Executive will
have to meet of course in the very near
future and it's up to them they'll make
that decision not me but although hope
is there will be a period when we can
have a good discussion within the party
and I think that's healthy and us to be
very welcome and I hope those that were
inspired by our manifesto will actually
join the party and take part in that
discussion it's up to them to set a
program for when intellectual take place
it'll be in the early part of next
year's quite often lead us down straight
away after a general action defeat like
this I mean this is a catastrophic
defeat many people would expect you to
stand down straight away I was elected
to lead the party and I think the
responsible thing to do is not to walk
away from the whole thing and I won't do
that I will stay here until
there has been somebody elected to
succeed me and then I will step down at
that point you talked about being
misrepresent do you feel you've been
misrepresented in the media yes
absolutely when we work at if you
analyze the coverage that's made of the
Labor Party you analyze the coverage
that's made of me you're looking at in
the eighties percent and above of
negative hostile or frankly just
downright abuse of individuals and
character assassination and constant
attacks on me and my family and others
and I just think we need to have some
consideration the effect this has on
politics when the whole political debate
is seen through the prism of personal
abuse and personal attacks
I never indulge in personal abuse or
attacks I never attack anybody
personally and the words I've often used
is I won't get into the gutter because I
think our lives and our politics is too
important for that just two more
questions when the history books declare
where the Jeremy Corbyn was for or
against remaining in the EU what should
they say I hope the history books will
say he's somebody that did campaign to
remain in the referendum in 2016 we all
know what the result of that was and
that after that what I tried to do was
negotiate an agreement with the EU so
that we could have either remain or
leave but leave with a trade
relationship with Europe what I don't
want to see is this country cut off from
the continent of Europe because of the
obvious trading relationships and all
the personal and family relationships
there are because I think for us to
become sort of offshore tax haven a
Europe would be a very very retrograde
step and we cannot allow ourselves to
become some sort of trading arm of the
United States on the shores of Europe
either who should be your successor well
that is not for me to decide the party
will elect somebody as a successor and I
look forward to supporting that person
and what will you do I will be the MP
for Islington North and very proud to be
the papers intern north and I will
continue to do
the campaigning work I've done all my
life on this series of social justice on
issues of housing and issues of human
rights around the world and of course of
environmental sustainability because
that is where I spent my life doing and
that's what I'll spend the rest of my
life doing jeremy corbyn thank you very
much